What's popping guys. It's this very special day.
It is Saturday in the morning and we have a special guest.
Okay. Now we don't have special guests. Uh, it's only me today, but you know,
we can still have fun with just me. Um, I don't have any plans for today.
You know, none of my friends invited me to anything,
so yeah. Um, so yeah, let's go, right. Uh, let's go right in web app, you know,
cause because there's nothing else to do apparently, but come on in.
[Inaudible].
Okay. All right. So let's write a simple web app.
I don't know what I want to build. All right. So usually what I like to do,
I like to start off with a template.
So usually what I do is I like to put it on Heroku. I like the host on Heroku,
cause it's just a lot faster and I don't need to think about the servers and
stuff like that. So I made a template called node JS template.
And what am I going to do is I'm going to get clone it onto my computer
and then maybe rename it to something else. Maybe called project.
Joma no project find Joma a wife.
Uh, and then let's go here as you can see, let's see if it works,
no JS index. Ooh, something's wrong. Cannot find module.
That is because we have to NPM install first.
So this will install all the packages that my template uses.
Let's look at package dot Jason. Jeez.
[Inaudible].
But yeah, so we've got express EJS okay. That's cool. Cool. Cool. All right.
So express is basically a web framework and uh, yeah, so let's try it out.
No GS dot index listening. Let's see. Local host 5,000
seems to work real well. All right. And then next, uh,
I kind of forgot how to do this, but next I'm going to deploy to Heroku.
So Heroku create,
get pushed to Heroku.
Come on, come on. You're compressing done.
Launching [inaudible]. Oh, they gave me this URL vast hollows. All right
. And then let's see if it works. Okay. Cool. All right. Joan
was a sounds right. So as you can see, now it's already deployed to
vast hollow. So now I have the deployment ready. So I am ready to code, but I'm not a coder. I'm not a
rapper. All right. So now I think about why do I want to build? Hm
. So usually I like to think of a problem that I have and then find a solution for it. So all I have to do is find my most annoying problem. I need a girlfriend.
All right. I'm going to take a break. I'm going to go get lunch, but um,
I'll think about it. I'll think about what to build. Yeah.
I'm Mr. [inaudible]. I have no buddy [inaudible]
um, Mr. Lonely
shy had some,
one to call on the
[inaudible]
away from
[inaudible]. Um,  Mr. [inaudible]
I wish that I.
So if I bought it and
I kind of want to build something for me and my non-existent girlfriend,
so that we can watch YouTube videos together and it'll sync together, you know,
for example, if I play and I pause or I stopped the video,
it's going to do the same to her. Or if she does the same thing,
now this probably already exists, but it's good practice, you know? So,
all right. Uh, let's start building this out.
All right. So first we're going to take off this abomination of a page. Okay.
So we're going to take off this, this gusting picture. Okay.
Take this off. Okay.
And then next, what we're going to do is we're going to learn about the YouTube,
uh, player embedded player, Java script.
Okay. And then we read the documentation and see how we use it.
[Inaudible].
Okay. See what this looks like.
Cool. All right.
So now we have a YouTube player and what I'm going to do is I'm going to learn
about how to, you know, use the JavaScript to play, stop,
pause, and also I'll, I'll make it a little bit more pretty. All right. First,
we're just going to make this a little bit prettier,
change that to seven 20, change this to four 80. Uh,
see what it looks like. Okay. It's a little bit bigger. Cool.
I want to change it to this prettier video because I like
to, I like to have fun while I code, you know, but I'm not a coder though.
Oh, very nice. Okay. Oh, wow.
Okay. And, Oh, I don't like the margin.
I think I'm just going to increase the margin a little bit.
So let's go to CSS mean there's no more headshot.
Let's put this to the player and then margin top.
Let's change it to maybe 50. Let's see if that, see, that looks good.
Okay. That looks a little bit better. All right.
So this is it for the aesthetic, uh, just so that I can code better.
So I have more motivation to code now.
And then what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna look at this API.
I'm going to figure out a way to send these information to my server
so that I can sync it between all of the people on,
off the people on the website, watching the player.
So after looking at the API,
I realized that they don't have everything I need it's because sometimes I kind
of just want to send the request to play or to stop to my server before
they actually play. But the YouTube player doesn't allow me to do that.
So I'm going to have to make a controller that is an extra layer
above the YouTube player so that I could send a request to my server without it
having to actually play.
So I do that so that I can actually synchronize both of the users while
they watch it.
So the first thing of what I did is I stripped out all the YouTube player stuff
and how I did that was, um, I read,
I read the documentation and I learned that you can take out the in controls by
controlling zero disable, keyboard, shortcuts, modest branding,
and stuff like that. But now we've got to add our own stuff.
So what we're going to do is we're going to add some buttons.
So I usually just go, let's see,
bootstrap button got a few con and then I just
copy this. So right under the player, uh,
I'm going to make a diff called the clear controls or something.
All right. Button here.
Maybe add another button. So I want to add a play button.
Oops.
And I want to add the pause button. Okay. That's what it looks like.
All right, cool. So we've got these two buttons now, and now we need a timeline.
We need a timeline because we need the user.
We need to allow the user to skip around and also to know where they are.
So yeah, let's just add that real quick.
[Inaudible].
And then that's it. Now we got our bar and it seems to work pretty well.
Yeah. Let's see if we restarted. Yeah. And then it starts the video and yeah,
it seems pretty accurate to me. All right.
Unfortunately we're out of time because it's already been almost 10 minutes.
So next steps, the next steps would be to connect the backend and the front end.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to connect them using WebSockets to
communicate with each other. If you don't know what web sockets are,
don't worry about it. I'll explain on the next video. So yeah.
So you feel like this video, don't forget to give it a like,
and I will comment for the first 30 minutes of releasing this video. So,
uh, yeah. Comment and don't forget to press the bell button for notification.
So that next time you could comment and I'll reply. All right.
So I hope you enjoyed this and a PISA.
[Inaudible].